hi there put Akoni axe my name is John
Green I'm a novelist and also a video
blogger when I was watching tonight's
debate I was struck by the fact that
it's that rare occasion in the world of
political debating where there is a
clear winner the winner of course was
Tom Brokaw aside from being the longest
surviving of the big three network news
anchors what what's that
dan Rather is still alive really is he
like in a home or something
no he's on HDNet Jesus I'd rather be in
a home okay fine aside from being the
longest surviving network news anchor
who works for an organization I've heard
of I think we can all agree that Tom
Brokaw's performance was fantastic he
was funny and charming and showed an
excellent grasp of the issues by the way
I apologize if this is poor quality
vlogging I played a drinking game during
the debate where I had a drink every
time someone said fundamental difference
or my friends so of course I'm sure
lacked the second winner of the debate
behind Tom Brokaw has to be Barack Obama
he sounded smart he sounded ready to go
he sounded fired up and while he was
sounding that way John McCain was busy
walking around the background of the
stage like he was lost this debate was
all about the economy and I agree with
the plurality of undecided voters and
saying that Obama just knows how to
handle that subject with a little more
clarity than McCain regardless of
whether you think Obama won the debate
or you're for some reason crazy I want
to say thanks for watching and
participating in our political process
and I'll see you some other time in this
campfire lighting